- Good morning Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn how success
is the hangover of failure.
Over to you, Marc Ecko.
(rooster crowing)
(rap music)
- I think the best advice
that I could give you
on success is to know that success
is merely the hangover of failure.
And that failure is an
essential ingredient
in creating a learning atmosphere for you.
So that you can accrue those learnings,
those small, incremental, steps of failure
and collect enough learning so
that you can arrive at success, right?
I think that we're taught in the system
that failure is something that
you should be ashamed of.
Failure is for the dumb kids
cause you get an F, you get a D, right?
You're not competent, you didn't comply.
You didn't create the
evidence of your worthiness.
And I could tell you, as
someone who's successful,
right, both financially, from a
wealth creation point of view,
but more importantly
a wealth that matters,
that success doesn't look like an A+.
It doesn't look like 110 in extra credit.
And failure isn't as simple as an F.
And it's not always, like,
failure can be very gray, right?
And being able to discern
what you might arrive at
an event in your life
where you think that,
"Wow, I've succeeded."
And you're getting the affirmation
from all these outside forces.
But if it's not aligned authentically
to who and what you are,
it could very much feel like failure.
- Failure is only real failure
if you don't learn anything from it.
We're so caught up on failure as
being this really bad, negative thing,
and what happens is people take one shot,
and if they don't hit, then they quit.
In what world do you take
one shot, and make it?
It's very rare.
It takes a shot, after another
shot, after another shot
in business, in life,
in athletics, in music,
anything that you want to do.
You will suck at the beginning.
You will fail over and over
and over and over again.
And because people don't
hit it on their first try,
they're convinced that it's
never going to work out for them.
And quite often, then they become
the little man to other people and say,
"Because I didn't achieve my goal,
now you can't go out and
achieve yours either."
It's never going to work
and they become this
super negative person who
just brings everybody down.
Most people are so afraid to
fail that they don't even try.
And that's the biggest failure of all.
Understand that it only
takes one thing to hit
for you to become a massive success.
If you look at actors, a lot of people had
a tiny role, after a tiny
role, after a tiny role
and they look back on their roles now
and they cringe on their acting abilities.
But that's how they got started.
And none of those were hits
and eventually they had
their big break through.
You look at entrepreneurs,
it's the same thing.
A lot of entrepreneurs start
with a little business,
and a little business and
another one that doesn't go well.
And it under, and a little business.
And then they come up
with that idea that really
takes off and they make their
first successful company.
If we look at my YouTube
channel as an example,
I've done so many videos.
4,000 videos on the channel.
And it took a long time
before any of them hit.
If you look at the Top
Ten series, as an example,
I tried that as one idea.
And that was one out of tons of ideas.
And that idea hit.
And then that became from once a week,
to twice a week to five times a week.
And thanks to your feedback,
we're able to collect 3,000 plus votes
on different people to profile
because I never thought
that we'd have enough people to profile
52 in a year.
I thought that was maximum.
Double that, 100 in a year,
let alone five times a week.
I didn't think we had enough content.
And you guys provided it to me.
We have cut more series on this channel
than most people create.
I'm okay with cutting.
I get an idea, the first
thing I want to do,
and here's the process,
the first thing I do when I get
an idea is I want to try it.
Test it.
Don't make it some big, crazy thing
that becomes impossible to ever do.
If you get an idea, find a low cost,
low, super easy way to
get started on trying it.
And see, do you like it?
Does it make you come alive?
Do you want to go do it again?
Was there any kind of reaction to it?
How can you make it better and tweak it?
Or, it was not enjoyable.
I don't like doing that.
I don't want to do it anymore.
People didn't like it either.
So we're going to cut.
Success will come again when you combine
the thing that you love doing
with what the market wants.
The thing that you
absolutely have a passion for
with what people want.
You have to have both.
If it's just what you want,
then it's just a hobby
that you do for yourself.
If it's just what the market
wants, consumers want,
then you're never going to be the best
because you're only doing it for money
and you don't have a passion to
really be great at that business.
Has to be the combination.
What you love doing,
with what people want.
And if you love doing it,
you haven't figured out
what people want yet,
then keep hustling, hustling, hustling
until you can find value to those people
so you can build a great business.
But the next time you get this great idea,
something that you want to do,
stop just making a list of different ideas
that just, we keep adding
to our list of to-do's
a list of ideas that one day
we want to do something about.
Get over the fear of failure.
Start small.
Take that idea and find a way, today
to move forward on it and see,
does it make you come alive so you
want to keep doing it
again and again and again
and if not, throw it away
and move on to the next one.
Failure is only feedback.
Failure is only showing you a way
of how not to do something.
And if you have that deep passion
for learning how to do it,
don't quit on your dreams
because you're afraid of failing.
So the question of the day today is:
I'm curious, what is one
of the biggest lessons
that you've learned from
failure in the past?
Leave it down in the comments below,
really curious to find out.
I just want to give a quick shoutout to
Michelle Bridgman from
michellebridgman.com.
Michelle, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying reading it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
(rap music)
- You eventually joined
Harper's Bizarre US.
And in 1976, it was, you were fired?
And I find that extraordinary.
- No, they were very
clear in that they thought
that I would never understand
the American market.
I remember I was the editor
on one shoot that was,
I think it was a French fashion show.
And I decided that it would
be interesting to have
dreadlocks on the models.
And I think that that pushed them further
than they could bear.
So that was it for me.
But I think it's always part of life
to have some knocks as
well as some successes.
- And to take risks?
- And to learn.
So I think it's healthy for everyone
to lose a job as well as to gain a job.
- You wake up in the
morning, you're failing.
So you blame the President,
you blame Congress,
you blame Greece, blame the Euro.
I mean, construction industry,
it's the mayor, oh, it's this.
And you wake up in the morning
and you look in the mirror,
and you're not failing because
it's the other guy's fault.
Or it's the economy's fault.
But if you look in the mirror and said,
I'm failing because of
me, you wouldn't like it.
And you'd change that.
And I believe the common denominator
of failure in any business is excuses.
As long as you wake up
and blame poor sales
on the economy, or an environment,
then you have no motivation
to make it better.
Because it's not your fault.
But in the worst economic environment,
four or five years in this country ago,
the we've seen in our lifetimes,
there were people making a
lot of money weren't there?
In the height of that recession,
there were people selling advertising,
people opening restaurants,
people building businesses.
Somebody's making money.
So the excuse is bull, it's bull.
So wake up in the morning
and own your failure.
Look in the mirror and say
I'm failing because of me.
And you won't like it.
And then you'll change it.
But as long as you don't put it on you,
you have no motivation to change it.
So in short, if you own your failure,
you'll own your success.
If you don't own your
failure, you'll never dig out.
And I find that in any business.
Always the common denominator of failure,
personally, is excuses.
You don't want to be a failure do you ?
- [Audience Member] Not at all.
- You don't want to look in
the mirror and experience that.
If you can't blame anybody but yourself,
you're going to change.
You're going to fight
it out. That's the deal.
- Failure is part of life.
I mean, the difference for me though
is I look at failure as a
stepping stone to success.
It's a speed bump. I
know I'm going to fail.
But it's not failure
if you learn something.
And so, gosh, I've made so many mistakes,
I've screwed so many things
up but every time I do,
it just becomes, it becomes
a way for me to explain
to someone else what it takes.
You know, it's like,
here's what I've done.
I think I have the ability
to influence people
because I talk about my failures.
I talk about all the
things that mess me up.
But I show people that I
didn't let them stop me
and you don't let it stop you
and I think that's
really the secret there.
- Right and if everything
you touched was successful,
you might not be able to
relate to people as much.
- No you won't be able to relate
and also, it's total bullshit.
And everyone would know it's bullshit.
And also, you'd be bored silly.
I mean, think about it, if you just said
I want this and it happened,
you know, people don't value
what they don't fight for.
And it's like, you see kids sometimes
and your parents will say,
"You're not going to value
this if you don't work for it."
and you're a kid going,
"I'll value it, just give it to me."
but it's true, you know?
The things we work the
hardest for we value the most.
So I think, you know,
the purpose of a goal
is not getting it anyway,
the purpose of a goal is who you become.
Who you become is going
to make you happy or
it's going to make you sad.
So, I'm not looking for
an effortless approach.
There's no such thing.